beer
I'm in Rotterdam on my way to the
biggest and busiest harbour in Europe
every day hundreds of vessels sail in
carrying cargo from all over the world
I've come here to meet a young man who
works on board a cargo vessel this is
urine right now he's in the middle of
his shift
cleaning out old fuel from the ship's
fuel tanks
Jeroen is 20 years old than a Seafarer
from the netherlands
he's an apprentice onboard the vessel
and he's studying for a career as a
ship's officer
but right now he's still learning and
has to do everything including the dirty
stuff
the ship just arrived here in Rotterdam
after a week's journey on the ocean
walking on board feels like I'm entering
a different world ships like these are
much longer than a soccer field and can
carry thousands of tons of cargo I get
to talk to you rune during a break I'm
curious if he knows what happens when
ships like these die and end up in ship
breaking yards in the developing world
so I do know what's going on in those
countries and it's really kind of
ridiculous you know that
with the with the technology of today
and safety equipment and everything it
still has to go in such a way because
it's just cheaper you know
the people walking barefoot and
and everything is as just sad you know
before they go to the ship breaking
yards these big vessels can live up to
30 years they handle a huge amount of
the world's train around 90% of the
world's stuff is transported by ship
after work we go inside the boats to the
sleeping quarters urine shows me his
room where he's living for his
five-month shift on board it looks
comfortable he has an ocean view and a
private bathroom but I do notice that
something's missing there's no posters
or pictures on the walls to remind him
of his friends and family leaving them
behind doesn't seem easy you told me
that you didn't sleep very well last
night
wait was it at all because you were
thinking about your girlfriend or was it
just something different yeah sometimes
you worry a bit about things like like
how do I do this or how do we do that
and how is it going with my girlfriend
and my family and you know what are my
friends doing at this place at the right
moment you know are they having a party
or maybe hanging out and a lot of things
which I miss you know because I just
can't be there because I'm on the ship
and yeah sometimes you can worry about
it but yeah I try not to think about it
too much
hmmm hello Jeroen sends text messages to
his girlfriend every day but he hasn't
seen her since the day he came on board
three months ago the next day Jeroen and
the crew are preparing for a ship
inspection they need to make sure
everything works perfectly
today the engine is getting a tune-up
your rune helps lift it out of the room
below the engine is heavy and fragile
there are only 12 men working on the
ship so there's plenty of work to go
around
sometimes even the seafarers need a
tune-up after a long day of work this is
where they come to work out their
frustrations it's the craziest gym I've
ever seen everything is made from old
boat parts including the bench press he
lets me give it a try
you see it's not that bad you have a bad
day just work out and forget everything
that's
your rooms coworker Oliver is from the
Philippines one out of every five
seafarers in the world is from there
when your room gets a full time job
he'll work for about three months with
no break but most Filipinos work for a
year or more non-stop to send money to
their families I have the biggest
respect for these guys that they can
manage it to do it and every day they
even if it's raining -20° thick layer of
ice on the ship and you know and still
they're working and that for eight
months straight yeah it's really crazy I
think for us in Europe it's it's almost
unthinkable to do this kind of work for
that small amount of money which they
get
your ruins job isn't really popular with
young people
right now more than half a million
people work as ships officers but 20,000
jobs are open and that number is
expected to increase the shipping
industry thinks young people aren't
interested in a physically demanding job
where they'll be away from home for
months at a time but hanging out with
your rune it's clear to me that he
enjoys it even through the tough times
soon the ship will leave Rotterdam to
sail again to the next port do are you
ever afraid you ever think about there
being an accident on the ship or
something dangerous happen
I'm not afraid but you have to keep it
really in mind because there's always a
possibility that something goes wrong
you know and and it's quite dangerous
there are so many things that can happen
if you see what we're lifting and with
what weights we're working and what
amounts of cargo you know the dangers of
the cargo the dangers of sailing on a
ship you know if you're in the middle of
the ocean and something happens to the
ship yeah you know it's it's quite
dangerous for example no more and I'm
where we're standing right now if it
snaps yeah we won't be standing here
tomorrow how long do you think you want
to do this for maybe when I got children
I want to quit and a search for a job
ashore you know but maybe I will do this
for the rest of my life until I retire
or go down with the ship you know it's
yeah
you